c'est l'une des polémiques qui a explosé
avec le confinement celle de la
fermeture des commerces liés à la
culture jugé comme non essentiels les
libraire disquaire et autres
indépendants ont vu une nouvelle fois
fermé du jour au lendemain
leurs portes au public sauf que dans le
même temps les supermarchés autorisés à
ouvrir car jugée comme essentielle
laissé quant à eux l'accès à leur rayon
culturel une contradiction mise en
lumière et sur laquelle le gouvernement
a décidé de statuer en interdisant la
vente de biens culturels dans ces
espaces
la vente des produits qui sont d'ores et
déjà interdite dans les commerces de
proximité donc l'interdisant dans les
grandes surfaces
une décision jugée arbitraire est
totalement absurde par de nombreux
français
d'autant que certains autres commerces
comme les blanchisseries teinturerie les
ventes d'ordinateurs et de produits
multimédias ou encore les journaux et la
papeterie sont quant à eux autorisés
pour de nombreux artistes et commerçants
cette décision est incompréhensible dans
un pays comme la france dont la culture
est un pilier essentiel
un argument auquel l'état oppose le
principe de santé publique
alors êtes vous d'accord avec la
fermeture des rayons donnée essentielle
alors justement notre témoin du jour
c'est isabelle bonsoir isabelle enfin
merci d'être la bête vous d'être
commerçante dans l'essonne et malgré le
confinement c'est seulement ce matin
qu'isabelle a fermé les portes de son
magasin de chaussures pourquoi pourquoi
parce que je trouve injuste qu'on décide
pour nous j'ai toujours la base qu'il
faut qu'ils se mettent en colère c'est à
dire les petits comme nous parce que les
petits commerçants dans la part l'équipe
voilà ils sont prouvés dire jusqu'à
maintenant quand on vend comme des
petits commerçants les noms et des
commerces de proximité
mais aujourd'hui c'est très fiers d'été
un petit commerçant on est petit bon bah
on assume
mais laissez nous travailler alors des
policiers faisait des rondes pour vous
intimider son nous voir la police pour
vous fermez et ben écoutez sont venus un
début de match sérieux on va dire vers
2h oui là deux heures attention si on
revient un peu plus tard vous serez
obligés de fermer et je leur ai dit à
des questions m'emmener emprise au fait
ce que vous voulez mais je reste ouvert
jusqu'à la fermeture
c'est tout pour calculer le rythme que
j'avais aucun pour vous dites
aujourd'hui kiss ass on vous avait dit
façon je suis au bord de la faillite
cherche au bord du gouffre donc c'est
toute façon si on continue très
longtemps qui n'a pas d' aide suffisante
pour tous ces commerces proximité en
tout cas dans mon métier c'est clair
quand j'en viens la plupart de nos
commerces seront fermés
alors qu'est ce que tu disais non
y'a un truc qui me paraît hallucinant
parce que effectivement je sais quel
point c'est compliqué pour vous et pour
beaucoup de métier mais soit ce virus il
est vraiment dangereux et effectivement
en reste 400 mille cinq cent mille morts
en france
et là c'est pas vous qui vous permet
c'est fermé tout pays et les gens à
acheter
est ce qu'il faut pour bouffer et basta
et là on attend le fignoler nous
avançons peut acheter du dr frys allait
chez le podologue
mais c'est hallucinant soit c'est
vraiment dangereux et on doit arrêter
tout tout de suite toiser pas dangereux
et laissez nous vivre mais tous les
comédiens les théâtres les cinémas les
commerçants parce qu'il ya un vrai
problème et on ne sait plus du tout où
on en est et là vraiment il ya un vrai
problème je comprends bien que vous
soyez là ya pas de sens c'est une fois
de plus vous êtes des routes ces
amazones m effectivement c'est arrivé
voilà mais moi je vais vous dire moi ça
c'est mon gros coup de gueule au site
favori c'est que amazon ils ont prouvé
qu'ils payent pas leurs impôts en france
ils vont se gaver on soutient la même
voiture je vous le dis il faut que hama
sont horribles et à finir les petits
commerçants les personnes confirmées
amazon va encore se gaver c'est
insupportable
ils ont pris plus 48 cents là où il ya
les jours c'est un major train coquilles
parce que comme des grandes surfaces a
bien su fermer
ah oui il est clair qu'il doit y vont
c'est la nuit pour ça on va pas en
vouloir amazon d'avoir une idée de faire
du commerce en ligne dire que c est moi
tout dans ce serait c'est pas le gros ça
n'aurait pas l'autre et je termine si
vous promettez cetc c'est juste que
effectivement ils vont se gaver comme
vous dite extra bon tant mieux pour eux
effectivement il faudrait qu'il paye des
impôts en france et qui soutiennent et
fit commerçants demandent maintenant
pardonnez moi madame mais votre attitude
est totalement irresponsable
ab c'est à dire que c'est pas mon
éthique et responsable chez désolé si
j'ai bien fallu qu'on se met en colère
pour qu on lui dit que ça s'est
tellement c'est tellement tout le monde
et écouter la preuve étant c'est que ce
que benjamin disais à l'instant c'est
que le gouvernement effectivement ce
torrent 2 pour savoir qu'il doit rester
ouvert ou qui doit fermer
mais c'est pour essayer de continuer à
faire vivre un pays parce que le
gouvernement est pas complètement
irresponsable et qu'il sait qu'on dépend
aussi de l'économie et que l'économie va
pas faire plus de morts qu'elle
coronavirus à c'est une situation
extrêmement compliquée mais je dis
pardon d'être redondant syrie jeudi
exactement la même chose qui hier nous
devons c'est un impératif être
solidaires de ceux qui nous gouvernent
et qui font au mieux pour nous et mais
oui voilà
je parlais juste d'amazon quoi je pense
c'est inadmissible qu amazon ne paye pas
et n'être pas l'état savait grâce aux
franchisés notamment ça c'est
inadmissible
oui j'ai nos gouvernements nos
gouvernements nos gouvernants sont
extrêmement mou avec un malade je suis
trouvée je suis d'accord sur place un
hyper mais les petits commerces pourquoi
madame est désespérée on parle d aide
les aides redescendre pas les grandes
surfaces bon là ça va être fermé wanda
leur place des trucs et amazon vend que
toi à leur place
oui tiens certes on est en train de
mourir et il faut de l'optimisation
fiscale paye jamais dans bien sûr on va
toucher pas au maire il faut qu amazon
paye ou consensus tant que ça c'est ça
je suis second suspect à ma connaissance
et non c'est une fausse soleil amazon
c'est vous tous nous tous à la wii donc
arretez ya un projet vous le savez
depuis longtemps de taxer les gaffes
mais ça fait même c'est je vois dans les
bars tabac par exemple je fume pas mais
il ya encore des libraires foot et dans
les bars tabac lors des libres ici de
moeurs
c'est vrai que je ne les écoute pas on
ne discute pas et si on vous écoute moi
mais c'est très compliqué moi je pensais
que cette notion de non essentielle me
déplaît il faudrait où il aura fallu le
baptiser différemment alors justement
les livres et dvd c'est non
l'alimentaire et la boisson oui produits
d'hygiène louis-ii vêtements non
journaux et papeterie oui oui fleurs non
maquillage d'abord non et puis après ils
ont fait ma gueule ils ont du matériel
automobile louis l'électroménager nos
matériaux construction oui jouer non
meubles non produits d'entretien oui
bijoux non voilà alors oui je suis
d'accord avec toi et je suis d'accord
avec tout le monde sur amazon mais
madame s'il faut pas trop taper sur
amazon que les gens qu'est ce qu'ils
font quand ils achètent ils vont au
moins cher faut les comprendre si les
gens n'ont pas d'argent une cote de tpm
dans une boutique ça va être 15 euros
sur amazon ça va être 4 euros parce que
c'est fabriqué à l'autre bout du monde
par un gamin d'un an de 6 ans
moi je ne trouve pas ça n'a fait pas
amazon ou si on ne fait pas amazon
peut-être parce qu'on a les moyens
moi je suis d'accord avec série près de
soi on dirait pas parce que c'est le
business tu peux pas cela je rejoins
philippe tu peux pas interdire à amazon
de vendre le business psb tati faudrait
peut-être qu'il faudra sauver ta marge à
amazon sur une taxe sur la marge de même
0,1 pour cent c'est bien sûr c'est
énorme et c'est pour les jouer c'est
terrible ce qui va se passer pour les
jouer vous n'allez pas interdire les
français d'acheter des jouets à leurs
enfants
alors j'espère que le gouvernement c'est
ce qui fait quand il ferme les magasins
de jouets les rayons jouets je fais
confiance parce que les gens achèteront
quand même les jouets mais qu'est ce qui
se passe sur amazon offre et la demande
mais ça c'est normal c'est une business
aussi pour par amazon il ya des produits
qu'on doublé de 15 20 % c'est à dire que
même amazon augmente ses prix oui même
amazon un canapé que vaut que mon beau
frère devait acheter à 110 euros et
n'est pas ça cent soixante dix ans le
même canapé mais c'est l'offre et la
demande mais c'est l'offre et la demande
c'est non non c'est pas drôle d'accord
mais tout ça tout ça n'est pas drôle car
dont je ne veux pas faire de de défendre
l'indéfendable je suis d'accord avec ce
que vous venez de dire il faut qu'ils
payent des taxes mais on peut quand même
pas reprocher amazon le virus n'est que
le moyen d'accès 500 mais cyril le seul
moyen d'acheter safe
aujourd'hui on n'en voulait placer cette
heureuse pas mais il faut qu'on taxe les
gars ça fait ça fait ça c'est sûr
toujours pas fait madame line pour vous
avez fermé votre magasin finalement
pourquoi ce matin alors j'ai fait ce
matin parce que nous avons obtenu des
choses qu'on demandait l'état quoi c'est
à dire en tournée un lieu justement
qu'on ferme les rayons dans les grandes
surfaces des produits non essentiels
d'accord à ce que vous voyez au jeu si
vous me permettez vous avez des grues
des façons pour vous parler vous avez
l'habitude moi je n'ai pas un jet
première fois que je passe des ministres
je vais vous dire je me suis amusé
drôlement a pas franchement déjà pour un
peu que vous connaître je ne connaissais
pas dit cela
j'ai regardé la première émission est
bien continuer c'est super si beaucoup
nous avons besoin aujourd'hui toute la
population qui est très angoissé a
besoin justement de rire et je tenais à
vous dire une chose s'appelle mois pour
justifier pourquoi nous élus ont
certains de nos élus encourage tellement
fait ce qu'il en fait je savais que ça
n'allait pas rester longtemps comme ça
mais il nous en fait pour une fois pour
nous protéger pour nous aider vous savez
où vous avez des commerces de proximité
une chose petit commerce on est rien
donc ça fait longtemps qu'on nous fait
tout ce qu'il faut pour qu'on
disparaisse et là c'est un peu trop donc
quand on lui a demandé
donc quand ils ont marqué demandé dans
notre ville on an'a cession de
commerçants qu'en janvier on est très en
retard batterie mais voilà il ya cette
nuit là j'ai attendu deux heures mais
c'est ma parole d'emmi laissez votre
avis que sinon neige et non mais bon
alors trois minutes plus tard pour que
je puisse parler dans ta gueule
c'est facile quoi les abat les sens de
ne pas nous on souffre énormément donc
on rigole parce qu'il faut se détendre
quand même mais on souffre notre mère je
tiens à le descendre pas c'est nous qui
avons demandé qu'ils fassent quelque
chose et non mais je suis dit c'est en
plein de choses et non c'est nous qui
avons demandé qu'on lui remercie
énormément d'avoir pris ce décret qui
nous a permis pendant une journée
d'avant tout l'été des visions sont
venus nous voir qu'ils nous ont donné la
parole
il est acquis a pris conscience que
laisser les les boutiques qui sont comme
les nôtres petite oreille à toutes les
femmes sanitaires tout lu tout ce qui
tourne nous protéger
depuis le déconfinement jusqu'à
maintenant on peut pas rentrer dans nos
boutiques ont tous rentrés à 2 3 maximum
moi j'ai 100 m 4 voilà donc c'est
n'importe quoi vous allez rire quand
vous allez là pour l'instant vous allez
faire mais j'ai aussi ouverte à partir
d'aujourd'hui parce que j'ai obtenu
quelque chose et je trouve qu'il faut
être honnête quand on obtient quelque
chose il faut respecter
vous avez maintenant non il devait
revenir vous allez mourir je vous fais
aujourd'hui
selon l humeur d'accord très bien au
club mais revoilà à accepter bat
isabelle bon on est seul à décider ça
bien là merci isabelle d'avoir été avec
mon estomac ils vendent beaucoup de
chaussures
merci à vous tous d'accord